is the newton and the apple story true
no
was it a different fruit
as a colleague of mine named simon
shaffer
in england
once said on a nova program that we were
both on
the role of fruit in the history of
science has been vastly exaggerated
okay
so was there any i mean to to zoom out
moments of epiphany
is is there something to moments of
epiphany or again this is the paradigm
shift versus the gradualism there is a
shift um it's a much more complex one
than that and we
i'm
as it happens a colleague of mine and i
are writing a paper right now
on one of the aspects of these things uh
based on the work that many of our
colleagues have done over the last
30 and 40 years um
let me try and see if i could put it to
you this way
uh newton until the
early 1670s
and probably really until a fair time
after that
first of all was not very interested in
questions of motion
he was working actually
in all chemical relationships or what is
called by historians chymistry a kind of
early modern chemical structure
colleagues of ours at indiana have even
reproduced the amalgams that
anyway
um
his way of thinking about motion
involved a certain
set of relationships
which
was not conducive
to
any application that would yield
computationally direct results
uh for things like planetary motions
which he wasn't terribly interested in
anyway
um
he enters a correspondence with his
original nemesis robert hook
and hook says well have you ever thought
about and then hook tells him a certain
way you might think about it and when
newton hears that
he recognizes that there is a way to
inject time that would enable him to
solve certain problems
it's not that he
that there was anything he thought
before that was contrary to that way of
thinking it's just that that particular
technical insight
was not something that
for a lot of reasons that are complex
had never occurred to him
at all and that sent him a different way
of thinking
but to answer your question about the
apple business which is always about you
know gravity and the moon and all of
that being no
um the the re the reason there is that
the idea
that um
what goes on here in the neighborhood of
the earth and what goes on
at the moon
let us say remind the sun and the
planets
can be due to a direct relationship
between the earth let's say
and the moon
is contrary
to fundamental
beliefs held by many of the mechanical
philosophers as they're called at the
time in which everything has to involve
at least a sequence of direct contacts
has to be something between here and
there yes that's involved
and
hook
probably not thinking terribly deeply
about it based on what he said
along with others like the architect and
mathematician christopher wren
hearken back to the notion that well
maybe there is a kind of magnetic
relationship between the moon and maybe
the planets and the earth and gravity
and so on vague but establishing a
direct connection somehow however it's
happening forget about it
newton wouldn't have cared about that if
that's all they said but it was when
hook mentioned this different way of
thinking about the motion
a way he could certainly have thought of
because it does not contradict anything
newton is a brilliant mathematician and
he could see
that you could suddenly start to do
things with that
that you otherwise wouldn't and this led
eventually to another controversy with
hook in which hook said well after
newton published his great principia i i
gave him how to do this and then newton
of course got ticked off about that and
said well listen to this i did
everything and because he had a picayune
little idea he thinks he can take credit
for it
okay
uh
so his ability to play with his ideas
mathematically is what solidified the
initial intuition that you could have
was that the first time he was born the
idea that you have action at a distance
that you can have
forces without contact which is another
revolutionary idea
i would say that in the sense
of dealing with
the mechanics of force-like
effects considered to act at some
distance
it is novel
uh with both hook and newton
at the time the notion that two things
might interact at a distance with one
another without direct contact that goes
back to antiquity
only there it would thought of more as a
sympathetic reaction
you know to a magnet and and a piece of
iron they have a kind of mutual sympathy
for one another
you